some of the biggest names in sports say
they were lost for words when they heard
the news about Kobe Bryant Feli fellow
NBA greats Kareem abdul-jabbar and
Dwyane Wade spoke out on social media as
did Neymar and other soccer stars Bryant
was a fan of theirs last night we asked
Caron Butler who also played for the
Lakers about their friendship and this
is a picture of Bryant with Butler's
family Brian said Butler was one of just
four teammates in his 20-year career
that he stayed personally close to as my
brother there's certain people that you
you meet along the journey saying you
recognize that it's bigger than
basketball that you guys are gonna have
a relationship way past the game and in
life and I recognized that immediately
once I met Kobe Bryant he taught me a
lot about this overcoming and not
putting ceilings or anything or
limitations on you know what you could
be capable of accomplishing in life some
people run away from challenges in life
Kobe presented a challenge of greatness